is there any part of you that ever goes
hey i could [ __ ] up my career right now
if i go out there and i'm you know i'm
all [ __ ] up on acid
and you know what i mean or you just say
you throw all caution in the wind
i already [ __ ] up my career so many
times at this point it's like if you
if you are out here expecting me to just
like
go by a go by the book then we've we've
hired the wrong person
just let me just let if you want me
there just let the good times roll and
i'll just
do you think that's why they cast you as
tommy lee in that poppy crew movie
because tommy lee has that attitude do
you think they saw that in you
i auditioned for that role six times
like this and the sixth time on the way
there
they had already like told me like yeah
dude it's it's there's
you know it's just you like you're the
only guy in the running for it at this
point like just come in for like one
last
you know reading and uh you know just
want to see how you vibe with the guy
who's going to play nikki sixx and on
the way there i got this i got in a car
accident
i don't have a driver's license so i
like got in this car accident
but i but i got hit though so i just got
out i looked at the car and i was like
i don't care if i get this roll i'll get
a new car anyway so i was like don't
don't worry about it i i
i get in the car i get to the audition
and there's another tommy lee
guy waiting there still i'm like dude
this is my sixth time like
give me the roll dude come on did you uh
hang with uh
tommy lee to get into the part or do you
just say you know i know enough yeah for
sure
yeah and and like
you know i mean one just ask i mean i'll
just flap the script down on his desk
and be like you know
did all this really happen how did it
happen like what did you sound like and
then the other
stuff was just like his mannerisms like
the goofy stuff like when he would just
stick cigarettes in his nose and like
somehow
get smoked to come out of his esophagus
i was like that's
weird you gotta teach me that and he was
like all right sure dude
take it stuff it up here he's like he's
like an exhale
he's like a jedi master he's teaching
ways of tommy lee
that must have been insane you could
probably write a book just about hanging
out with tommy lee for
you know like just a couple of days
you